Attention Deficit Hyperactive Disorder or
ADHD is the most commonly diagnosed psychiatric
disorder among children and teenagers. But
what’s going on inside the brain and body
of these individuals and could it actually
be an advantage?
While some environmental factors such as maternal
drinking and smoking during pregnancy may
play a role in brain development, ADHD is
highly linked to your genetics. And most of
these genes are directly associated to the
brain’s reward pathways. It turns out that
those with ADHD have lower levels of dopamine
receptors - dopamine being the ‘feel good’
hormone. This means they are less sensitive
to rewards, ultimately making them feel bored
or unstimulated by what may keep another individual
entertained.
We also see a major difference when we look
at fMRI scans. Normally, a brain at rest shows
activity in the default mode network, and
quickly switches over to the task-positive
network when your focus is required. But for
ADHD brains, the default mode network fails
to automatically shut down, meaning both networks
stay active, resulting in a decreased ability
to concentrate. Scientists have also observed
a thinner prefrontal cortex in ADHD patients,
which is responsible for attention control,
emotional regulation, and response inhibition.
As a result of these difference, Ritalin is
often prescribed for ADHD; it helps to increase
dopamine concentration in the synapse, increasing
the likelihood of it binding to the fewer
receptors . However, there is conflicting
research on its overall efficacy and concern
over unknown long term side effects. Of course,
many non-ADHD individuals have also been known
to abuse ritalin as a method to increase concentration
during work or school to study more effectively.
Perhaps more controversial is the dramatic
increase in diagnosis of ADHD over the years.
Whether warranted or not, a 5% increase was
documented each year from 2003-2011 in the
US. Medication prescriptions have also followed
this pattern, with some reports indicating
a 35% increase in dispensed prescriptions
from 2008-2012.
But it turns out that there may be an evolutionary
advantage to having classic ADHD symptoms.
For hunter-gatherers and nomadic cultures,
being restless and hyperactive translates
directly into higher chances of successfully
bringing home food and increased vigilance
for protecting offspring. This means a greater
chance of survival and passing on your genes.
Even in a current study of settled vs. nomadic
members of the Ariaal tribe in Kenya, nomads
that had a higher frequency of genes linked
to ADHD were better at getting food.
On top of this, studies have routinely shown
that those with ADHD tend to be more creative
in both controlled tests and in real life,
as they often think randomly and outside the
box. Finally, while structured and orderly
school environments may not be conducive to
ADHD children, many adults thrive in the right
work environment. Studies show that if their
high energy is channeled into the right careers,
especially those that demand great resourcefulness
and adaptability, this once viewed handicap
can become a strong asset.
Special thanks to audible for supporting this
episode to give you a free 30 day trial at
audible.com/asap. This week we wanted to recommend
the book ‘The ADHD Advantage’ by Dale
Archer, which highlights how some of the most
successful entrepreneurs, leaders and entertainers
were strengthened by their ADHD. You can get
a free 30 day trial at audible.com/asap and
choose from a massive selection! We love them
as they are great when you’re on the go.
And subscribe for more weekly science videos!